Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Imagina a una neuróloga brillante
llamada María.
María vive en un cuarto blanco y negro,
solo lee libros en blanco y negro,
y sus pantallas sólo
se muestran en blanco y negro.
Sin embargo, a pesar de
no haber visto nunca el color,
María es una experta
en la visión del color
y conoce todo lo ya descubierto
sobre física y biología.
Ella sabe cómo las diferentes
longitudes de onda de la luz
estimulan tres tipos
de conos en la retina
y sabe cómo las señales eléctricas
viajar por el nervio óptico al cerebro.
Allí, se crean
patrones de actividad neural que
corresponden a los millones de colores
que mayoría de humanos pueden distinguir.
Pero imagina que un día,
que la pantalla en blanco y negro
de María funciona mal
y una manzana aparece en color.
Por primera vez,
ella puede experimentar algo
que ella ha conocido por años.
¿Aprende algo nuevo?
¿Hay algo de la percepción de color que
no capturó todo su conocimiento?
El filósofo Frank Jackson propuso
este experimento mental,
llamado la habitación de María en 1982.
Sostuvo que si María ya conocía todos
los hechos físicos de la visión del color,
y el experimentar el color
todavía podía enseñarle algo nuevo,
entonces, los estados mentales,
como la percepción del color,
no puede ser completamente
descritos por hechos físicos.
El experimento mental de
la habitación del María
describe lo que los filósofos llaman
el argumento del conocimiento,
de que hay propiedades
no físicas y conocimientos
que solo pueden descubrirse
a través de la experiencia consciente.
El argumento del conocimiento
contradice la teoría del fisicalismo,
que dice que todo,
incluyendo los estados mentales,
tiene una explicación física.
Para la mayoría de las personas
que oyen la historia de María,
parece intuitivamente obvio
que realmente ver el color
será totalmente diferente que
aprender sobre él.
Por lo tanto, tiene que haber
una cierta calidad de la visión del color
que trasciende su descripción física.
El argumento del conocimiento
no trata solo de la visión del color.
La habitación de María
utiliza la visión del color
para representar
la experiencia consciente.
Si la ciencia física no puede explicar
por completo la visión del color,
entonces tampoco puede explicar por
completo otras experiencias conscientes.
Por ejemplo, podríamos conocer
todos los detalles físicos
sobre la estructura y función
del cerebro de otra persona,
pero todavía no entender
lo que se siente al ser esa persona.
Estas experiencias inefables
tienen propiedades denominadas qualia,
cualidades subjetivas que no se pueden
describir o medir con precisión.
Los qualia son únicos
a la persona que los experimenta,
como tener una picazón,
estar enamorado
o sentirse aburrido.
Los hechos físicos no pueden explicar
completamente esos estados mentales.
Los filósofos interesados
​​en la inteligencia artificial
han utilizado
el argumento del conocimiento
para a teorizar que
recrear un estado físico
no necesariamente va a recrear
un estado mental correspondiente.
En otras palabras,
la construcción de una computadora
que imita la función de cada
neurona individual del cerebro humano
no necesariamente va a crear
un cerebro computarizado consciente.
No todos los filósofos creen que
el experimento de la habitación
de María es útil.
Algunos argumentan que su amplio
conocimiento de la visión del color
le habría permitido crear
el mismo estado mental
producido al ver realmente el color.
El mal funcionamiento de
la pantalla no le mostraría nada nuevo.
Otros dicen que su conocimiento
nunca fue completo en primer lugar
porque se basó únicamente
en los hechos físicos
que se pueden comunicar en palabras.
Años después del experimento,
Jackson revirtió su postura
sobre su experimento mental.
Decidió que incluso la experiencia
de María al ver el rojo
todavía no corresponden a
un evento físico medible en el cerebro,
sin qualia incognoscible
más allá de la explicación física.
Sin embargo, todavía
no hay una respuesta definitiva
a la pregunta de si
María aprendería algo nuevo
al ver la manzana.
¿Podría ser que haya límites
fundamentales en lo que podemos conocer
sobre algo que no podemos experimentar?
Y ¿significaría que
hay ciertos aspectos del universo
que se encuentran de forma permanente
más allá de nuestra comprensión?
¿O permitirá la ciencia
y la filosofía superar
las limitaciones de nuestra mente?